c'est donc le début des vacances de la
toussaint elles vont s'étaler sur deux
semaines avec un retour sur le chemin de
l'école le jeudi 3 novembre certains
parents rencontrent des difficultés avec
ses dates pour s'organiser en cause le
début des congés en plein milieu de
semaine
plusieurs solutions sont envisagées
prendre des jours demandé aux grands
parents de garder les enfants ou encore
les centres de loisirs écouter ces
quelques réactions à la sortie des cours
ce midi ma femme travaille en éducation
nationale on n'a pas eu trop de soucis
car les vacances scolaires comme les
enfants et par contre moi je travaille
je continue à travailler ça ne pose pas
de problème pour nous pour garder des
enfants tout ça va presque c'est pas
assez pas l'idéal pour les autres
parents justement pour les vacances et
tout ça c'est pas parce que c'est lui
qui a voulu garder le petit oui parce
que sa mère nous a demandés sur l'été là
et que si hockey donc on nous comme on
n'est pas prouvée de partir on va le
garder toutes les trois jours là et
après ces paroles qui vont le garder ce
qui se trouve à cause mais si si on
n'avait pas été là bas alors il arrêtait
au centre propos recueillis par nicolas
landry